anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir à part le taux de participation
qu'il faudra surveiller à laval le
sceptre qu'est-ce que vous surveillez
année mais moi c'est la ville de mon
enfance donc c'est sûr que je connais
pas mal de quartier dans laval laval a
changé beaucoup les candidats
actuellement voudrait que la lutte elle
est moins moins agressifs qu'à montréal
donc les gens se chicanent pas mais on
est quand même des questions de principe
dont on parle beaucoup de textes non
pour avoir regardé un mot les différents
programmes donc veulent augmenter au
taux d'inflation ce qui est correct
d'autres veulent le juger mais offre
aussi des services
donc il ya quand même ça au niveau des
autres défis c'est défi environnemental
je pense que tout le monde s'entend
là-dessus ce que j'aime par contre c'est
le jeune de 25 ans qui a déposé sa
plateforme qui le dit prenez la prenez
les meilleures idées et essayer de
réaliser ce pour moi c'est peut-être la
nouvelle façon de faire de la politique
une idée est pas juste à une personne
mais si elle se réalise c'est bon pour
la communauté donc je trouve ça quand
même innovateur c'est innovant mais
aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
candidats femmes hommes c'est
intéressant c'est aussi la lutte va être
intéressante à regarder sur le plan du
terrain j'espère que les gens vont
s'intéresser davantage mais les
lavallois habituellement quand c'est le
temps d'aller voter ils vont qui vont
très bien mais monsieur vaillancourt ya
pas juste laissé derrière lui un
héritage de corruption une image la
corruption il ya aussi laissé désert en
matière d'urbanisme il n'y a jamais fait
attention à ce qui se construisait où ça
se construisait ou en fait il fait
attention si ça lui rapporter et donc la
ville était un peu à reconstruire à bien
des endroits en termes de protection des
milieux naturels même chose et c'était à
2% protection des milieux naturels les
candidats actuellement vice presque tous
17% moi je retiens ses fans boyer puis
michel trottier qui ont les deux des
poids des projets de protéger le
territoire 17 pour ça michel trottier
eux-mêmes protéger les golfs alors que
monsieur boyer lui veut protéger
seulement 50% et je suis impressionné
par toutes les plateformes on voit que
ya par exemple le verdissement des
centres d'achat la canopée
l'augmentation de la connecter la
notation de la plantation d'arbres on
n'est plus du tout dans les mêmes
discours qui lie 8 1 nice a fait plaisir
à voir ménage me demande je m'attendais
à avoir plus de grands projets
d'urbanisme de pour le centre ville et
pour l'ensemble des quartiers
laval
mon dieu vient discipline et le oui
je vais vous à mon autre panel à 17,1
très bien ok non mais c'est intéressant
mais quelque chose de moins drôle
de vraiment très laid il ya quelqu'un
sur qui envoyait un message de menace à
ballarat mahoney son vol l'écouté je
vous lirai pas le message parce que
c'est nul je suis lucide et c'est
dégueulasse mais la réaction de monsieur
dsk porté plainte à la police pour
menace de mort
j'ai reçu un courriel
manas de mort
me traynard l'amour et n est pour moi
c'est comme une commotion émotionnel que
j'ai eu ce matin ça m'a bouleversé
et ça m'a rendu triste mais celle-là a
été au delà de ce que je reçois
normalement normalement c'est le moment
n mais là avec la menace de mort puis en
parlant de suicide je pense que c'est
aller bien au delà de
la norme de la haine que je reçois
normalement on parle beaucoup de la
haine sur les réseaux sociaux qui est
qui qui peut influencer les politiciens
à se retirer de la vie politique parfois
mais là là c'est quelqu'un qui est qui
est allée trop loin qui va peut-être en
payer le prix le les gens dérangés qui
font des mandats ce serait internet
c'est de plus en plus courant je connais
plein de monde qui ont goûté à
différents niveaux et évidemment c'est
totalement inacceptable menacer une
personne dérangée il faut pas voir ça
comme moi je vois pas ça dans la
rassembler des courriers lièvre ou
courriel de haine mais des gens qui font
des menaces de mort c'est une personne
dérangée puis devra payer le prix année
pour l'avoir lu c'est assez dérangeant
effectivement en politique on voit
toujours le meilleur de lui-même aussi
le pays et c'est ce qu'on a vu là
effectivement les réseaux sociaux où
j'en ai été victime
régulièrement
dans mon dernier mandat et c'est pas
évident les gens se cachent derrière un
écran 10 ans voir ce qu'ils ont à dire
il ne dirait pas en face mais ils vont
le dire par écrit parce qu'ils sont sûrs
que ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est totalement inadmissible peu
importe qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
monsieur valeurs morales ou les autres
candidats c'est inadmissible de faire
par de tels mots parce que je lis lui
prévu c'est quand même assez dérangeant
parfait ça c'est réglé je pense que tout
le monde va s'entendre là-dessus par
ailleurs les annonces du jour je vais en
profiter madame plantes qui promet 15
plateaux sportifs sur des terrains
vagues aux arrondissements qui en ont
besoin ce coderre qui revient qu un
projet plus vaste viaduc notre dame en
parc linéaire il l'avait annoncé en fin
de semaine son intention de couvrir le
boulevard l'autoroute décarie dans snow
dunn est ce que monsieur coderre vise de
plus gros projets comme à naples en lui
qu'en pensez vous ben oui effectivement
le recouvrement de décarie pi2
l'autoroute ville-marie ça c'est des
projets à l'ats richard bergeron là et
effectivement c'est énorme par contre le
faire high line sur la partie de rootkit
à l'est du vieux du vieux montréal ça
c'est pas un grand projet tant que ça
puisque la structure existe et c'est
génial parce que ça sert à rien cette
affaire là sert à rien ça pourrait
devenir une expérience de vauréal oui ça
a coûté très cher 80 millions à l'époque
si je me rappelle bien ils ont vois pas
où ça mène mais là ça pourrait devenir
une promenade et s'il ya des on occupe
le dessous en plus c'est une excellente
idée le projet de mon empreinte aussi
est assez révolutionnaire pour connaître
les grands parcs et les sports à chaque
fois qu'ils croient pas osé tableau des
plateaux sportifs c'est des trucs à 1.5
millions ça commence à 1.5 union
s'arrête à 25 millions et lorsqu'on dit
si on va en enfer à 320 milles c'est à
dire qu'on va prendre des terrains
vacants on remet de la salle du béton de
terrain deux poteaux de basket c'est une
petite révolution aussi très bien annie
tout jamais lié aussi
favorablement toutes les propositions
mais aujourd'hui je suis bien contente
de voir que les deux candidats ont deux
positions différentes avec deux projets
qui sont différents et je suis d'accord
avec les deux projets celui celui de
monsieur coderre effectivement c'est un
grand stationnement dans le vieux
montréal les gens se stationnent leur
donc ça sert vraiment vraiment pas grand
chose ça va embellir le secteur et c'est
nécessaire et pour aussi le recouvrement
rio on a déjà vu celui d'eau de ville
marie à l'époque où monsieur coderre
était mal donc on a vu que ça se sait
capable c'est une possibilité que ça
puisse se réaliser il a essayé donc je
pense que c'est une bonne augure de
pouvoir continuer à le faire aussi c'est
un grand projet pour le projet de madame
plantes s'occuper des jeunes je trouve
ça intéressant moi j'ai toujours dit que
si on s'occupe pas des jeunes c'est eux
qui vont s'occuper de nous et si on est
capables les occuper sur des terrains
sportifs c'est encore mieux et
effectivement dans certains
arrondissements qui n'ont pas les moyens
de se doter de belles infrastructures
celle là pour faire la faire rapidement
une petite dernière avant de vous
laisser aller sur la vaccination que
coderre qui a peut-être pris de court je
sais pas madame plat l'asie aujourd'hui
moche pour une vaccination de tous les
employés municipaux
madame plantes du et c'est moi la
mairesse
le tour de table année on est tout pour
la peau de la tarte aux pommes tout le
monde aimerait surtout le monde se
fassent vacciner mais il faut avoir le
pouvoir de le faire pisser pas
malheureusement la possibilité et le
pouvoir de montréal d'exiger que ces
employés soient vaccinés si québec
délègue ce pouvoir-là la ville on pourra
le faire mais aujourd'hui l'heure on
peut pas eu obligé on ne peut pas le
faire dans les compagnies donc on peut
pas le faire plus à l'avenir si on
aimerait tout ce qui est beaucoup de lui
il ya beaucoup de villes à travers le
monde en commençant par san francisco
qu'il exige de 16 de leurs employés je
trouve que monsieur coderre en exprimant
cette idée là ont marqué un point et la
réaction madame plante est un peu de
dire n'est ce pas toi d'en parler mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas lui accorder
tout le monde en convient mais quand
même il ya mille initiatives sur la
table j'ai trouvé ça intéressant et ça
m'amène il reste combien resteront de
l'udc yanick madame plante est
aujourd'hui était la plus agressive par
monsieur coderre qu'est-ce qui se passe
beaucoup de gens de campagne
moi je pense que madame plantes par
rapport à monsieur kader elle fait un
peu de l'annulation c'est à dire au lieu
de discuter des idées monsieur kader
elle discute tout le temps l'homme par
exemple on va pas commencer à apprendre
afin d'apprendre ce genre de position là
je lui conseille de potes de discuter
des idées même si ce sont des idées que
qu'on ne peut guère pas entièrement la
ville de montréal ce sont des idées sur
le fond tali sur les fonds donnés sur le
fond ani le com vous fait d'air c'est
très apprécié les gens nous écrivent
beaucoup merci à vous deux déclenchera
leur erre d'aller jusqu'au 7 novembre
cette maman grande soirée vous allez
passer la scène ce dimanche soir de
cette soirée électorale avec merci merci
à vous